thank you guys we're here with lavona
rojan also finishing in the grand chess
tour a bit of a topsy-turvy tournament
for you but at the end how do you rate
your performance in the entire tour
um
not so proud i can say that but uh you
know i think
after the olympiad uh i really
i'm not uh feeling like myself so
it's okay you know uh
it's uh as
there is a saying you know it's a cloud
it has to pass so i'm waiting for the
cloud to pass and
things will be good again so
uh but
generally of course it's very enjoyable
to play here and the tournament is very
exciting with some very interesting
games so
and you regaled us with plenty of those
when you mentioned this cloud and you're
waiting for it to pass do you think that
this cloud partially is the fact that
you've been playing so much
no
i don't think i'm playing too much
because i
had a long
pause and
i i generally feel comfortable playing a
lot so
i
you know i can't imagine doing something
else throughout the day so
this is something that makes me happy
and plenty of chess upcoming for you
you'll be playing the 960 as well as the
us championship coming up that's right
yeah yeah absolutely
oh it's exciting to see you guys any
questions here for for the one as i'm
trying to keep an eye on this game
between jan and hans and the more i say
the more confused i get yeah i think
maybe we could ask
about this because we put him to work
come on our perspective has been kind of
on the record so
if you had if you didn't know anything
about what happened before do you think
white has
a lot of winning chances not a lot of
winning chances none whatsoever what's
happening here
i guess somehow maybe he needs to bring
his king to the king side and try to
play with f3 you know
that's my feeling because somehow
i don't see any way he can get any you
know
progress but
maybe his rook might get trapped yeah
uh
the rook is uh
is in awkward position
do you mean this rock on on aid or aid
right um
yeah somehow i think uh
i think black should have enough
counterplay here
it feels uh like
without seeing the previous if it feels
like black has comfortably got his rooks
active and uh his rook on a6 is uh
controlling the pace so
should be a draw i guess
yeah draw team's favorite the engine is
also dropping the evaluation and that
would give us a playoff an exciting
playoff here for the singh field cup of
course the grand chess tour has been
taken tell us a little bit about this
newcomer to the gct you know already
ferugia comes into st louis blazing hot
destroys the ceilings rapid on blitz
there's no other way to put it and then
performs very well here takes the gct
your thoughts on him
oh he's a brilliant player and a player
who doesn't get discouraged
and
he's a he's a great fighter so
it's very exciting to see
somebody who plays uh fighting chess to
you know perform well you know it means
for me personally i mean i'm more of the
romantic players so it's good to see
somebody
who's
doing something similar succeed and
it gives me hope in what sense
well you know if you can play
romantically and
maybe
slightly incorrect you know
it means this
chess is not all pragmatic you know so
chess is still
very much
a game where you can take a risk and
achieve success do you think his
practicality is what is currently
setting him aside from some of the other
players in this tournament or some
people from his generation
i think he's very impractical that's
what i mean
and that is definitely setting him aside
from from other players so
it's it's it's his comparative advantage
pride of advantage well thank you for
joining us here in the studio i know it
was a topsy-turvy grand chess tour but
certainly hoping to see you in the next
year's edition and very soon in the us
championship thank you very much quick
question for you
lavonne
a quick question but maybe a difficult
uh one to answer as well
world champion magnus carlson has
abdicated his throne
he is not going to be playing anymore in
the feed a world championship cycle
does this motivate you or the reverse
does this disappoint and depress you
it doesn't matter for me actually you
know it's
if
i regain my form i i don't care
who i'm playing you know i'm always
excited to play against anybody
so it's it's not that
i think magnus is unbeatable
there you go here you go thank you for
that
thank you uh lavon and good uh luck to
you in the official random as well as
the us championships we'll be calling
the action
and uh still peter we have this one game
remaining
yan